esta mujer que veis en pantalla es
alexandría ocasio cortez la mujer que
quiere convertir a eeuu en la nueva
suecia
se trató de la congresista más joven de
la historia de eeuu y una de las caras
más conocidas del partido demócrata se
define abiertamente como socialista
democrática tienen millones de
seguidores en twitter y otros tantos
millones de críticos tanto fuera como
dentro de su propio partido pensadlo
bien en un país como eeuu la palabra
socialista levanta muchísimas ampollas
sin embargo en un momento donde los
demócratas están en plena crisis de
identidad su discurso parece la fórmula
ganadora para las próximas elecciones
pero que defiende exactamente ocasio
cortez que es eso del socialismo
democrático en este vídeo te lo vamos a
explicar
hace unos meses sacamos un vídeo en
visual política hablando del cambio
ideológico dentro del partido
republicano con donald trump pues en el
partido demócrata está ocurriendo algo
muy parecido a fin de cuentas cuando un
partido pierde unas elecciones los
afiliados se preguntan el por qué y ahí
es cuando surgen propuestas de todos
en este caso podemos hablar de toda una
nueva generación de políticas demócratas
que ya han roto varios récords y si digo
políticas porque casi todas las
integrantes de este grupo son mujeres
por ejemplo tenemos ahí la no mar y a
rachid adlai que son las primeras
musulmanas en llegar al congreso de
hecho y la no mar será también la
primera congresista que llevará un velo
islámico- pero no solamente hablamos de
género y de edad esta nueva jornada de
política se define por tener una enorme
presencia en redes sociales y tener unas
ideas totalmente rompedoras dentro del
partido demócrata tradicional
pero sin duda alguna la representante
más famosa de este nuevo movimiento es
esta mujer que veis en pantalla
alexandría ocasio cortez la gran
abanderada del llamado socialismo
democrático como os podéis imaginar
ocasio cortez se ha convertido enseguida
en el blanco de todas las críticas de la
derecha pero no os equivoquéis la vieja
guardia del partido demócrata tampoco la
ve con buenos ojos por ejemplo una de
sus grandes propuestas políticas es el
llamado green new deal que es un paquete
de medidas sociales y ecológicas sin
embargo ni siquiera la portavoz de los
demócratas en el congreso nancy pelosi
está de acuerdo con este proyecto
en algunas entrevistas ha llegado a
despreciar lo abiertamente no deja de
ser sorprendente teniendo en cuenta que
ambas están en el mismo partido político
y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos
esto de el socialismo democrático no es
nada nuevo en eeuu a fin de cuentas es
lo mismo que defendía bernie sanders en
las primarias demócratas de 2016 y si
tenéis razón la diferencia es que ahora
no sólo hablamos de un candidato aislado
sino de todo un movimiento que parece
cada vez más amplio pero no sólo eso
bernie sanders podría ser muy de
izquierdas en lo económico pero cuando
llegábamos a los temas sociales era
mucho más moderado
por ejemplo no se oponía frontalmente al
derecho a portar armas y en temas de
inmigración o incluso de raza podría
pasar por un conservador sin embargo
tanto casio cortez como sus compañeras
son un punto y aparte en los demócratas
y tal vez un punto y aparte en la
política de eeuu así que la pregunta es
es posible que uno de los países más
capitalistas del mundo termine adoptando
un sistema socialista qué clase de
socialismo propone o casi cortes de
verdad tiene algo que ver con el modelo
nórdico el de los países como suecia o
dinamarca que dice seguir hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
vamos a ver un poco de historia
las viejas ideas ya sé lo que estáis
pensando muchos de hecho ya me puedo
imaginar lo que me vais a poner muchos
en los comentarios socialistas en el
partido demócrata tenga ya en eeuu no
existe una izquierda de verdad aunque
también sé que muchos otros sobre todo
los que estáis viendo este vídeo desde
el mismísimo eeuu me vais a decir que el
partido demócratas siempre ha sido
socialista anticapitalista y amante de
los estados fuertes que suben los
impuestos y encorsetan el mercado libre
y lo cierto es que ambos tenéis una
pizca de razón el partido demócrata es
uno de los partidos más antiguos del
mundo tienen casi 200 años de historia y
eso es muchísimo tiempo para cambiar de
principios para que os hagáis una idea
durante todo el siglo 19 los políticos
que defendían la esclavitud pertenecían
principalmente al partido demócrata es
más incluso décadas después de que
abraham lincoln que fue el primer
presidente republicano aboliera la
esclavitud muchos demócratas defendían
cosas
esto hemos reorganizado el partido
demócrata bajo una única premisa que
esto es un país de hombres blancos y que
los hombres blancos tienen que gobernar
lo benjamin tillman senador demócrata
por carolina del norte de 1895 hasta
1918 por supuesto que todo esto ha
cambiado radicalmente y hoy en día el
partido demócrata no tiene nada de
racista pero este ejemplo nos sirve para
ver cómo los partidos pueden evolucionar
ideológicamente y algo parecido pasa con
la economía en los años 30 franklin
roosevelt introdujo cambios radicales en
el sistema político y económico
estadounidense subidas de impuestos
estado del bienestar y muchísimas
medidas para regular a las empresas sin
embargo la administración de bill
clinton o incluso la administración de
barack obama fueron muchísimo más
moderadas
soy un ferviente creyente del libre
mercado soy un ferviente creyente del
capitalismo pero también soy un
ferviente creyente de que hay algunos
bienes comunes que requieren alguna
regulación
barack obama en otras palabras que el
partido demócrata engloba a toda una
amalgama de ideologías que van desde el
centro hasta la izquierda por ejemplo
abigail spielberg es una de esas
políticas que pertenece a la llamada
blood dog coalition que es el núcleo
centrista del partido demócrata pero
también tenemos a los más radicales
dentro de este grupo la cara más
reconocible es nuestra protagonista de
hoy alexandría ocasio cortez en una
entrevista a la cadena pbs le
preguntaron si esto del socialismo
democrático era algo así como el fin del
capitalismo y esta fue su respuesta
creo que vamos a tener una evolución sin
precedentes en nuestro sistema económico
y es difícil decir qué dirección va a
tomar alexandra o acaso cortes pero como
decíamos antes no es la única por
ejemplo y la no mar la primera somalí en
llegar al congreso también se identifica
como demócrata socialista sin embargo en
este caso es tan radical en sus
propuestas que ni siquiera los propios
socialistas la admiten en el grupo iv
porque os preguntaréis pues básicamente
por su posición en contra de los
asentamientos y la ocupación militar de
israel en los territorios palestinos si
veis este vídeo desde españa por ejemplo
seguramente no os parezcan posiciones
demasiado radicales pero en eeuu se
trata de una de las cosas más
controvertidas que se pueden decir
es decir que esta nueva oleada de
políticas demócratas están rompiendo
muchísimos esquemas mientras hacemos
este vídeo están investigando al
deutsche bank- por prestar dinero a
donald trump y han llegado a calificar
al banco alemán como uno de los mayores
blanqueadores de dinero del mundo y todo
esto estando a las puertas de unas
elecciones primarias
muchas de estas congresistas se podrían
presentar a candidatos demócratas para
las presidenciales y eso significa que
la próxima nueva presidenta del país
podría ser una socialista pero qué
significa exactamente eso del socialismo
democrático pues ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver
una importación europea socialdemocracia
seguro que más de uno ha escuchado esta
palabra en algún momento en realidad uno
de los partidos más importantes de toda
europa es el partido socialdemócrata por
ejemplo el partido socialista español
está encuadrado dentro de esta gran
familia ideológica pero de dónde viene
la socialdemocracia pues tenemos que
irnos a principios del siglo 20 en el
año 1917 estalla la revolución
bolchevique en rusia de repente el país
más extenso de europa da un giro radical
a su sistema político y decide apostar
por el marxismo leninismo
cuáles son los principios del marxismo
pues en este vídeo os lo explicamos más
a fondo lo cierto es que desde el primer
momento los bolcheviques rusos tenían
una vocación internacional por eso en
1919 crearon el llamado komintern una
organización que englobaba a los
partidos comunistas de todo el mundo su
objetivo era ayudar tanto con formación
como con dinero a todos los partidos que
quisieran seguir los pasos de rusia en
otras palabras todos aquellos que
querían una revolución comunista en su
país pero como en todo en esta vida el
está en los detalles y hay un
detalle muy importante cuando hablamos
de la revolución comunista atentos
los comunistas no quieren conciliar sus
principios ni sus objetivos declaran
abiertamente que sus fines deben ser
conseguidos mediante el derrocamiento
por la fuerza de todas las condiciones
sociales preexistentes manifiesto
comunista capítulo cuarto exacto los
comunistas buscaban acabar con el
capitalismo mediante la violencia y aquí
es donde surge la gran brecha dentro de
los movimientos de inspiración marxista
por un lado estaban los comunistas puros
que querían revolución por otro los
llamados socialdemócratas cuyo principal
referente sería rosa de luxemburgo
básicamente los socialdemócratas querían
acabar con el capitalismo usando las
herramientas de la democracia liberal es
decir presentarse a las elecciones y
poco a poco cambiar las leyes hasta
terminar llegando a un sistema
socialista para los comunistas rusos los
socialdemócratas eran unos traidores a
la clase obrera si duermes con el
enemigo tarde o temprano te terminarás
uniendo a él pero lo cierto es que los
partidos socialdemócratas funcionaron
muy bien en toda europa al menos desde
el punto de vista electoral
y sin duda alguna la zona del mundo
donde más poder consiguieron fueron los
países escandinavos suecia dinamarca y
noruega tuvieron gobiernos
socialdemócratas durante décadas y por
eso todos estos países tienen estado del
bienestar muy generosos con sanidad
universal muchísimos servicios públicos
y por supuesto impuestos altísimos y por
eso seguro que todos habréis oído a
muchos políticos decir que defienden eso
del modelo nórdico
entre otros nuestra amiga alexandría
ocasio cortez cada vez que alguien la
acusa de querer acabar con las
libertades y la democracia
estadounidense ella dice que su modelo
es suecia dinamarca y oye a ver quién
dice que no a eso a fin de cuentas tanto
suecia como dinamarca tienen estándares
de vida fantásticos quién no querría
vivir en copenhague con un sueldo de más
de tres mil dólares al mes colegios y
hospitales públicos verdad pero la
pregunta que nos deberíamos hacer es de
verdad podemos decir que los países
escandinavos son socialistas pues ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
el modelo nórdico los comunistas tenían
razón en una cosa si sigues las reglas
de los burgueses terminas convirtiéndote
en uno de ellos y eso es exactamente lo
que ocurrió con todos estos partidos
socialdemócratas poco a poco todos ellos
terminaron abandonando el marxismo y el
anti capitalismo
de hecho si veis este vídeo desde españa
recordaréis el congreso de suresnes con
felipe gonzález donde el psoe
oficialmente abandonó el marxismo y lo
sacó de sus estatutos
es que la premisa básica del socialismo
marxista es la propiedad social de los
medios de producción ojo porque esto es
muy importante de matizar un comunista
no tiene problemas con que tú tengas tu
propia casa o tu propio iphone eso son
bienes de consumo es decir que los
utilizas para tu vida diaria el problema
está cuando quieres tener fábricas
empresas o máquinas con las que puedas
producir bienes y en el futuro podrás
vender en el mercado eso es lo que en
economía llamamos bienes de producción o
bienes de capital y ahí es donde los
comunistas no son amigos precisamente de
la propiedad privada
pero de todas formas todo esto lo
explicamos más a fondo en un vídeo que
os dejo en la descripción por cierto que
si os interesan estos temas
recordad que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas
las semanas así que suscribiros a visual
política y darle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones pero vamos a seguir con
la historia porque ahora os preguntaréis
y esto cómo se consigue y es eso de
socializar los medios de producción pues
hay muchas formas de colectivizar el
capital desde nacionalizar empresas
hasta crear cooperativas donde los
trabajadores también son accionistas y
ahora diréis hay muchas cooperativas en
suecia pues lo cierto es que no de hecho
si hay una tendencia en estos países es
precisamente a todo lo contrario
suecia lidera el ranking de
privatizaciones ningún país ha
privatizado y desregulador servicios
públicos tan rápido como suecia según un
estudio del fin tan conservador
fundación heritage para que os hagáis
una idea la fundación hey dates publica
todos los años un ranking de libertad
económica en el mundo según este ranking
eeuu es la decimosegunda economía más
libre del mundo dinamarca es la
decimocuarta y suecia la decimonovena
durante los últimos 20 años estos países
se han privatizado casi todas las
empresas públicas incluso en algunos
aspectos
suecia es bastante más capitalista que
eeuu por ejemplo en el sistema educativo
eeuu fue uno de los primeros países del
mundo en garantizar educación universal
y esta educación se da en colegios
públicos pagados y gestionados por el
gobierno bien sea a nivel federal oa
nivel estatal
el caso de suecia es distinto en este
caso tenemos cada vez más escuelas
privadas compitiendo con las públicas
por supuesto que el estado garantiza que
todos los ciudadanos puedan recibir
educación pero a los ciudadanos se les
da el dinero y son ellos quienes a
título individual pueden elegir el
colegio donde quieren llevar a sus hijos
a este sistema se le llama cheque
escolar y algo parecido ocurre en la
sanidad donde cada vez están entrando
más y más y más empresas privadas y lo
mismo ocurre en dinamarca para que os
hagáis una idea en estos dos países ni
siquiera existe el salario mínimo si si
habéis oído bien por supuesto que
existen políticas de protección de
trabajadores y seguros de desempleo pero
no tienen un salario mínimo así que
cuando casi el corte
propone un sueldo base regulada por el
estado de 15 dólares la hora no sé muy
bien dónde habrá sacado la idea pero
desde luego no de los países nórdicos y
todo esto explica las declaraciones que
dio el primer ministro danés en una
visita oficial a eeuu
sé que hay algunos en eeuu que asocian
el modelo nórdico con un tipo de
socialismo así que me gustaría dejar una
cosa clara dinamarca está lejos de ser
una economía planificada socialista
dinamarca es una economía de mercado es
verdad que algunos impuestos son más
altos que eeuu por ejemplo en dinamarca
el tipo marginal del impuesto sobre la
renta puede llegar hasta el 56% eso es
muchísimo pero también deberíamos
preguntarnos qué ocurre con los modelos
de gasto de otros países por ejemplo en
eeuu la deuda ya supera el 105 por
ciento del pib es decir el gobierno debe
dos veces toda la producción que genera
la economía norteamericana en un año
en dinamarca en cambio la deuda no
supera el 35% esta es una reflexión que
debemos tener en cuenta y lo mismo pasa
con el déficit es decir que la casa
blanca gasta mucho más de lo que ingresa
y en el largo plazo eso puede traer
problemas en otras palabras que por raro
que suene los países escandinavos
ofrecen muchísima más estabilidad para
los negocios el resto explica que haya
tantísimas empresas privadas nacidas en
esta zona del mundo por ejemplo h&m la
cadena de tiendas de ropa o spotify el
servicio de música en 'streaming' son
compañías suecas
por supuesto que hay muchas propuestas
del caso y cortez o de bernie sanders
que si podrían encajar con el sistema
nórdico por ejemplo la sanidad universal
pero hay muchas otras que buenas o malas
no tienen nada que ver con el modelo
nórdico así que ahora la pregunta es
para vosotros creéis que esta nueva
oleada de políticas demócratas llegará a
tomar el control del partido vamos a ver
una nueva revolución ideológica al igual
que la que estamos viendo dentro del
partido republicano podéis dejarme
vuestra respuesta en los comentarios si
te gusta do este vídeo dadle a like y
nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta pronto